the Joe Rogan experience there's this
really strange idea that people think
that Jews cause anti-semitism right like
when the evil man who walked into the
Walmart in El Paso talked about a
Hispanic invasion and then went into
that Walmart and killed I think upwards
of 20 people no one thought maybe he's
right maybe there is a Hispanic invasion
maybe that was like somehow justified
because he saw them as insular or
isolated or looking out for each other
do you know what I mean like that would
be a crazy idea right right and yet when
it comes to the Jews people are like
well you know they wear their funny hats
well you know they seem to you know be
looking out for one another I mean like
but do you think they were that kind of
rationalizations after the tree of life
horrific massacre do you think that
people were saying that like hey they
wear their funny hats they like people
just looked at it like this is horrible
this is disgusting in that case yes but
not in the case of what's been going on
in Brooklyn there we keep hearing things
like this is the result of communal
friction as if you know disputes over
zoning laws cause someone to pick up a
machete the size of a broomstick
walk into a rabbis house and hack people
up that was the story I emailed you
about yeah it's just do you see what I'm
saying so like in the case of tree of
life let's take that that's like a very
what that's like a clean case in the
sense of these are innocents mostly
elderly - two of the brothers who I knew
who were killed or mentally disabled
okay was the people that show up to
services on time which is a certain kind
of person and you have this white
supremacist
who says all Jews must die he's totally
unequivocal about it he and he goes in
and he tries to do that so you have just
a case of someone who any reasonable
person sees is evil which is this
neo-nazi and people who any reasonable
person see is totally innocent which is
you know Jews in prayer was the guy the
shooter killed no he's standing trial
yeah dude and there were and and he
actually embodied this thing sorry I
stopped no I just what the question was
like who do
when they have something like that do
they extensively interview him and try
to figure out what the [ __ ] brought him
to that
I mean is he schizophrenic is he well a
lot of the people like the guy in the
Munsey case that we're gonna talk about
the machete guy he showed signs of
mental illness I think that Robert
Bowers in Pittsburgh also did but you
know but then so did Dylan roof the guy
that killed however many people he
killed at the Blackshirts Church in
Charleston South Carolina but he was
also white supremacist it's like these
hateful ideologies often they draw
people that are deranged or young or
somehow on the fringes of society but
with a guy in Pittsburgh he was deep
into this replacement theory ideology
the reason that he selected tree of life
is his synagogue is because tree of life
the previous weekend had participated in
this program called national refugee
Shabbat or Sabbath it was celebrating
the idea of welcoming the stranger which
is a fundamental Jewish value do not
oppress a stranger because you were
strangers in the land of Egypt and he
said specifically that you know highest
the group that was organizing this
National Refugee Shabbat it stands for
Hebrew immigrant Aid Society it started
in the 1800s as a way of resettling
Eastern European Jews who were fleeing
pogroms in Eastern Europe now works to
resettle refugees including Jews all
over the world and he specifically
selected tree of life because of that
because he said the Jews are bringing in
the dirty immigrants into this society
so he was like kind of the perfect
embodiment of white supremacists
replacement theory ideas in Brooklyn
it's much harder cases because it's much
harder for people to talk about because
how do you talk about the fact that in
many of these cases and a lot of them
have been caught on CCTV you know that
it's a young black man attacking a
Hasidic guy walking down the street and
who's visibly Jewish it's much harder to
talk about when someone is someone who
we talk about as being rightly as being
from a group that is himself victimized
a poor black kid in Brooklyn is then
going on to victimize another minority
group it's just much harder
when the attacker is not a white
supremacist to talk about it that down
is a strange one the Hasidic one is a
strange one but in some ways I think
it's easier for ignorant people to look
at them as the other because the way
they clearly distinctly dress they dress
so much different it's almost like if
yet Amish people move in and they stuck
to themselves they lived in one sort of
community I think they would probably
experience a similar level of hatred but
then you add into it the sort of
acceptance of anti-semitism in a lot of
communities it's like it's ramped up but
there's this myth that the Jewish
communities of Brooklyn are interlopers
they've been there for more than a
hundred years they've been in Crown
Heights in Borough Park than before
Caribbeans before lots of other
communities the mythology like mythology
yeah the interloper the cultural vulture
the evil landlord like these are
themselves expressions of the
anti-semitic idea and people don't even
realize it well I think there's also a
genuine jealousy in the accomplishments
and achievements of Jewish people you
know I mean if you look at Nobel Prize
winners from from Europe in particular I
mean how many of them are European Jews
it's [ __ ] stunning
you know it's stunning when you look at
the amount of lawyers I mean we don't we
just joke around about my Jewish lawyer
yeah you know I mean it's it's like a
standard thing you think of doctors and
how many successful and educated people
are Jewish and that's one of the things
you actually touch a touch on in in your
book you you were talking about I mean
it's how but then why successful Jewish
people have become in this country and
there's got to be some sort of a
resentment for that as well especially
by again we're talking about mentally
deranged people people with like severe
some of them are mentally deranged but
some of them are young some of them are
that's what's really difficult and
fashionable yeah yeah it's like the the
disease is sort of like unleashed you
know it's like Dylan roof was mentally
ill but he chose a black church he
didn't choose you know a white Mormon
Church right it's like the guy in Muncie
he was mentally ill by all accounts but
he googled you know like why did Hitler
hate the Jews and he googled various
synagogues yeah I mean the really
and you know do you remember last time I
was on here the Covington video remember
the Covington duplicate that had just
come out right do you remember in the
video there were those two or three
black men who were members of this sect
the black Hebrew Israelites the Hebrew
Israelites and everyone kind of laughed
them off is like haha they're just this
obnoxious weird sect
well they their ideology right the idea
that the Jews are not the real Jews that
were pretenders to the faith that the
Jews are behind the slave trade that the
Jews are subhuman vermin that was the
ideology that informed this recent
attack in Jersey City I don't know if
you followed that one that was the one
where it was a couple and they were
driving or they wanted to target police
officers and Jews and they targeted
these officers and Jews yes yes they
hated pigs and they hated Jews that's
what they there were diary entries and
Google searches and think I mean it
sounds horrible to say but they I went
the next day to Jersey City to see to
see the aftermath of it and they had
targeted specifically this kosher
grocery store and they ended up killing
I think for people but literally this
right above the grocery store to the
left it's a grocery store and then a
synagogue and above the synagogue is a
school where there were like 50 young
children and thank God they weren't
murdered then they find comes to light
if you'd like a week ago that they had a
bomb in the u-haul that had the range of
five football fields that they wanted to
deploy I mean and everyone was laughing
ha like look at these crazy people that
believe this crazy ideology well this
crazy ideology is moving people to do
very very violent things and their think
that things that haven't even made the
news you know like you know if if we
believe this idea right that the that
this what's going on in Brooklyn is the
result of communal friction well how
does that explain my friend's
father-in-law who was walking on the
Upper East Side wearing a yarmulke on
his head and gets the [ __ ] kicked out of
him
how does that explain my friend of Rahm
who is a progressive Jew wears a rainbow
yarmulke is on the subway and he has
he's had several interactions with this
group who scream at him hold one of them
held up a picture of
with Farah Khan saying you're not a real
Jew you're a [ __ ] all of these
horrible things this is like creeping in
everywhere I had a friend on the Lower
East Side that was visibly Jewish not
wearing a black hat wearing a yarmulke
but looked like you were me got punched
this was like two years ago
by a black Israel no he was just a
random guy but that's no not all of
these are black Israelites what I'm
saying is that there's this kind of
inchoate
hate that's like being unleashed and
that's the thing that's most disturbing
like if you look at the anti-defamation
league statistics only a small
percentage of hate crimes committed
against Jews something like 15% last
year were committed by white supremacist
they're among the most violent and the
most visible but who's the rest of them
that's actually more alarming to me the
fact that it's like coming from all of
these different directions and how do
you contain it once it's been unleashed
[Applause]